hi I'm Benna trainer sloths I'm the
vice-president of 24 by 7 here at Google
and I'm here today to talk to you about
reliability in the cloud leveraging
cloud allows customers to achieve
outcomes of scale reach speed and
flexibility which would be difficult or
impossible to achieve for many companies
and many services for this talk I'm
going to focus on reaching high levels
that reliability for services running in
the cloud here at Google we've been
building extremely reliable services in
the cloud for two decades now and along
the way we've learned a lot about what
works well and we've also found some
pitfalls and we're gonna help you avoid
cloud offers a lot of power and a lot of
options for building reliable systems
and that flexibility is great but it
also means that cloud offers some new
and interesting ways to get reliability
wrong and because public clouds work
differently than many of traditional
on-premise data center environments the
reliability paradigm that works well in
cloud is also somewhat different from a
traditional setup and we'll cover that
so today I'm going to give you a
framework for understanding your
reliability goals and how to achieve
those goals in cloud i'll cover three
distinct topics defining requirements
choosing an architecture and design and
implementation and execution and
deployment this talk is adapted from
Google's own internal best practices for
building and maintaining cloud based
systems when we use those same practices
to implement both customer facing
products like search Gmail and YouTube
as well as our own cloud infrastructure
so first you need to define business
requirements or reliability and I want
to emphasize how important this step is
this is the requirements stage for
reliability and we all know
intellectually that getting requirements
just so is critical before you proceed
to design an implementation but we also
know in practice that sometimes we don't
spend enough time on requirements and
that can be especially true for a
requirement seems a little
softer squishy like reliability so when
we talk about reliability often the
temptation is to say our reliability
requirement is 100% or it always works
or we assume that the infrastructure
provider is going to be perfect right
and that turns out to be closely but not
actually the correct reliability target
so the outcome of this exercise will be
reliability requirements and targets for
you to use along with a way to measure
them so this slide is critical it is you
know the the central idea behind our
approach to reliability and this comes
from our own experience right what we
find is that there is a sweet spot for
sending a reliability target which
bounces between the two basic
considerations that we have in
reliability the first is user
expectations right if your product is
insufficiently reliable you select too
low a target and you deliver that target
your users will not like your product
and they will eventually leave you for a
competitor and everyone pretty much
understands this where I departed the
simpler doesn't work most of the time is
not to be a great product but what we
don't understand quite as often is that
if your product was perfect if it
delivered a 100% uptime your users
experience will still be far from
perfect right because there are lots of
sources of unreliability in the end and
chain that your user experiences right
their device may not work if you have a
mobile device and it malfunctions one
time in a thousand when we were trying
to reach some site you would say that's
a very good very reliable mobile device
yet that's only three nines right and so
if your users can't tell the difference
between three nines of availability and
perfect availability then the user
benefit that you get from making your
applications far more reliable is de
minimis but part two the cost of
reliably right goes
exponentially as you approach for
affection and so you can see on this
chart this basic idea right as
reliability approaches perfect the user
benefit becomes nearly zero and the cost
rises exponentially and so the perfect
target for reliability which balances
the cost in terms of both direct dollars
and your development velocity of
reliability and the marginal benefit of
increased reliability turns out not to
be a hundred percent for your
application but rather a number that's
very close to a hundred percent very
common number is ninety nine twenty nine
five percent availability up to ninety
nine point nine nine percent
availability simply because the other
systems that are in between you and your
user typically are not more reliable
than that to begin with and picking this
target which is just shy of perfection
both keeps your costs way down and also
allows you the ability to develop new
features and new functions for your user
it's not more quickly because you're
spending less engineering time on
working on perfection and in practice
that ends up being a good choice for
achieving user happiness so when we look
at reliability in addition to this idea
of picking a conscious choice that's a
bit short of perfection the other thing
that we find is that it's really
important to do the reliability exercise
in a coordinated way across your
different teams right this allows you to
make decisions about the reliability of
product components that support the user
actions that they're taking with your
application and here in current right
not all user activities have the same
requirements for reliability right for
your business or for their value
different activities have different
expectations and that again is an
opportunity for you to strike a more
cost efficient and appropriate balance
on the whole for your users and for your
application instead of holding every
part of your system to the same
high-water mark of the most critical
user activities this approach also help
you avoid unexpect
and unwanted uneven behavior of your
application where some parts work you
know very very well maybe more well than
you need them and other parts and
disappoint your users because they don't
work as well as it's required so let's
talk about how to define this process
right in Google terms we use something
called SL ice or service level
indicators as a way of measuring the
end-to-end availability of a
particularly user activity and we use
SLO S or service level objectives as a
term to describe the expectation for how
those SLI is emerging practice for our
users right and so if you end up with SL
is that accurately measure your users
activities and SL owes that numerically
describe what those SLI should be in a
well running system you have something
very useful which is a set of
measurements that are machine measurable
right so you can actually measure them
constantly record them go back and look
at them later alert on them when they
aren't working the way you want and they
also allow you to tie the behavior of
your system to specific systems specific
components and specific development
teams who are working on the system and
that in turn allows you to manage your
development and deployment process and
it allows you to make decisions about
how we run your service on a cloud so if
that's all a very abstract concept let's
talk about this in practice and I'll use
obviously and it made up example here
but one that we can mostly relate to so
suppose I'm doing an assessment for a
banking application and as you can see
on this slide I've listed the business
goals in priority order right we have
several user activities and those
activities map to business goals right
for each of those goals I've mapped out
the relevant user activities in my
application and I can see that really my
top goal is to retain the customers that
I've got and I know that in order to do
that I need to be sure that the users
can conduct their most common and
important activities logging in checking
their account balance access
their money very very lively so for each
of these steps I've defined slis right
and in this case I've defined that the
user flow consists of logging in right
accessing their balance accessing the
application to begin with and I can
instrument this with test devices and
emulators and I can break apart the
front end and the back end so that I get
more fine-grained SL eyes but at the end
of the day the crucial SLI that I'm
measuring is this user journey of
opening up the application logging in
and performing the activity right and so
now I can look at what the user
experience is I can break it down into
the sub pieces of user experience so
that I can tune or debug and I can have
an overall measurement that tells me
whether the application is working the
way I want it to and therefore the way
that the users will be happy with now
there are some other user activities
that are described here and we can see
that those are lower priority that
doesn't mean that they're not important
right obviously if you know we can't
sell our users new product so that's
very bad for the business but the
reliability requirements for those
activities is actually somewhat
different right for example if if
someone applies to take out a loan and
there's a problem with the system it's
probably a reasonable result to say no
application received and we'll have an
answer for you within 30 minutes even if
you wanted your ideal result to be that
the user gets the answer that instant
they'll have a relatively low attrition
by the short delay but that covers for a
huge amount of downtime like 30 minutes
a month right is not even four nines of
availability so this idea of describing
and documenting your different music
journeys and assigning them an
appropriate SLO allows you the freedom
to either allocate development resources
are allocating in a way that that lets
you build a great product for your user
rather than focusing on making
everything perfect so with this concept
of SLO and SLI describe let's talk about
architecture and design
have to achieve those numeric goals for
availability
so the first step obviously is you'll
have to choose a cloud provider or cloud
providers and you'll have to learn how
their infrastructure works well enough
to know how it can support the SLO is
that you've chosen for your own service
so first thing to realize is regardless
of which cloud provider you choose they
will also not be perfect right that
cloud provider will consume part of the
unavailability budget that is inherent
in every SLO right and this would be
true whether you were building something
on-premise or whether you're building it
with a public cloud provider right and
each of them has different services that
they offer in different s ellos for
those service and so this is where it's
very important for you to look at the
services that are provided and the s
ellos that are given for those services
and also the SLO s that you could
realistically expect if you were to
build that same service yourself right
and questions to ask at this stage
knowing what SLO you're aiming to
achieve with your own application are
you know does the provider offering
prospective components that exceed the
measured and actual uptime that you've
experienced with your on-prem
environment right not your target but
what have you seen in practice does the
provider offer tools that make the whole
stack more reliable like tools that
allow you to debug or quickly discover
where there are problems reducing the
duration of account time you may have
and does the provider make it easy for
you to achieve your desired outcomes
with SLO s and this step really requires
some digging and some research but it
pays off hugely because it affects how
you build your application and how you
deploy your application and then again
you know the end result of how your
users experience your application so
when deciding which provider can best
support your reliability SLO s you also
want to look at the infrastructure that
they offer in terms of the zones and
regions right
that is now a common across all of the
public cloud providers but basically
zones are the fundamental building block
of cloud infrastructure right they're
easy to reason about and they're easy to
program for the analogy is a single data
center right and like a single data
center they are both well understood and
there's limits to how much reliability
you can expect from the single zone so
if you need more reliability than a
single zone can offer then you're going
to need to run your application in
multiple zones or multiple regions and
if we go that route it's important to
understand what you get and what you
also don't get from both running in
multiple zones in the same region or
running in multiple zones in multiple
regions so let's talk about
infrastructure and availability right
the easy outages and the ones that we
often find we're talking with customers
about are the ones on the left right you
picture a data center and you picture a
data center on fire it just jumps to
mind
well jumps to mind if you've been doing
reliability for 20 years so just in my
mind you picture floods you picture
tornadoes you picture you know utility
power failures these are the big very
dramatic very easy to to empathize with
outages um but in practice if you look
at the headlines from the last five
years and say well what had been the
causes of public cloud provider
infrastructure downtime it's actually
not any of those things all of the
interesting outages that we see almost
all the outages are really due to
software or external software events and
not these you know dramatic easy to
imagine hardware delivers right so you
have network control plane failures you
have global denial of service attacks
you have BGP hijacks you have
authentication system failures you have
configuration changes that went awry
right none of these things are actually
related in hardware none of them would
cause the data center to look like a
tornado had gone through it the data
store would look identical
yet the impact on on your service and
impact on that particular zone region is
the same right everything stops working
so you know while we're on this topic we
can actually talk a little bit about you
know current events right we can learn
from what's happened with the curve 8:19
pandemic with kovat we saw you know
another unexpected event that really
caused no damage to the physical
infrastructure but caused huge changes
in the usage pattern from users and for
here at Google we saw for example huge
increases in video conferencing use with
our meat product and while we were able
to scale up and meet that demand through
moving resources around we also saw
other instances in industry where demand
clearly had surged and the providers or
the services struggled to meet the
increased demand and that was if you
will a failure of scalability or a
failure of flexibility still a logical
failure rather than physical failure but
one more example of why that are the the
things that you should worry about are
not the things that look dramatic or are
up here in your mind's eye so much as
the logical problems that actually are a
bit more mundane but really dominate the
downtime that we measure the data so
coming back to this discussion of zones
and regions the bottom line is not that
physical failure to never happen if they
do but rather that they're not actually
what the data tells us we should focus
on because they are de minimis in terms
of their impact on your application and
logical failures are really the thing
that we must pay attention to so for
those services that actually require
physical separation or physical
isolation for for example regulatory
reasons we actually recommend that you
look at using multiple regions rather
than multiple zones because both regions
tend to be physically more distinct than
zones where it's owned by average with
public cloud providers
about 10 kilometers apart from each
other regions tend to be hundreds of
kilometers apart from each other and so
you get more physical redundancy for
much of the same logical work that's
required to make your application run on
multiple locations the other reason that
we recommend multiple regions however is
that on all of the providers the logical
isolation that you get between different
regions is significantly higher than the
logical isolation that you get between
zones and the same region and so in
practice what we see is that an
application that runs in multiple
regions will have many fewer logical
failures that it's exposed to than an
application that simply runs in multiple
zones inside the same region ok so at
this point you've got your user journeys
described you've got your s ellos and
you're working on this question of
should I use multiple zones or show you
multiple regions or is a single zone
sufficient for my needs you also at this
point want to consider how easy the
provider makes it to deploy instances of
your application across multiple
locations whether it's zones or regions
you know generally all of the public
cloud providers offer regional versions
of their services that automatically
distribute the data and processing user
traffic across the multiple zones in
region and you can use their offering or
you can roll your own but generally what
we would recommend is that you use the
versions of those tools provided by your
provider for two reasons right one is
they have many more flight models on
them than whatever you're going to build
yourself and two is you benefit from all
of the other customers who are also
using those tools and therefore the
investment of the cloud provider will be
making in improving those tools over
time and we've seen that there's a
temptation to look at those systems and
say well they haven't been perfect so I
should build my own because I know I can
build my own perfect system but actually
as experienced professionals we all know
that building your own version of a
multi zone highly available highly
performant system is actually quite
tricky it's both expensive in terms of
develop time and it's difficult together
and then you'll have to maintain it and
improve it for forever so I would
encourage you to by default use the
tools that are provided to you rather
than rolling your own in cases where
those tools are available so if you look
at the building blocks again that cloud
providers offer you we can see here in
this example map rights with three basic
options right you can run a service in a
single zone represented by one of those
circles you can run a service in several
zones inside the same region which still
means you don't need one of those
circles again or you can run your
service in two or three regions using
one or more zones in each of those
regions and you can see right that the
separation that you get physically is
quite large between regions so there
will be increased latency between the
regions but also there's a great deal
more physical isolation that's provided
by the regions and then as I mentioned
there's also a great deal more logical
isolation and here again it's important
to look at the provider or providers
that you're using right because
different providers do it differently I
won't spend time talking about the other
cloud providers but in the case of
Google Cloud we do offer features that
make running in multiple regions much
easier for example we have single global
interfaces that allow you to view and
manage the resources that you've got
we've got products that automatically
will allow you to select a multi
regional offering and that do data
replication and data processing across
multiple regions and then we have a very
large very high bandwidth backbone
network that allows you to transfer data
between regions and do load balancing to
distribute your traffic across multiple
regions so putting this all together you
know what do you want to look for in a
cloud provider and how do you want to
think about your architecture for
account providers right I would say
first and foremost you should ignore the
marketing and look at the data the
performance data from the different
cloud providers is different
and each of them has some pros and some
cons and you want to look at how those
pros and cons would affect the
application that you're trying on and
the availability targets that you've
chosen for yourself
and pick one that's the best match for
your particular needs I would say
secondly you want to look at the
strengths of each provider in terms of
their infrastructures security right
infrastructure attacks themselves are a
reliability problem if there's a DDoS
and no one really cares whether it's
your application or your providers
infrastructure that failed to protect
you right all the users will know is
their application stopped working and
they're angry with you and so it's
important to look at the track record of
dealing with large-scale attacks and
large scale security challenges and make
sure that the infrastructure providers
that you are using meet your needs in
those regards you should look at the
size maturity and scalability of the
providers infrastructure again picking
on denial of service attacks right those
attacks tend to be very large there are
public reports of attacks in the multi
terabit range and so size does matter
and scale doesn't matter
and picking providers that have both the
resources in the track record to be able
to absorb very large attacks when they
happen will give you a degree of
security and protection that you
otherwise wouldn't have or similarly if
there's been a major shift of demand as
the result of for example coded right
does the provider have the experience
and the track record of being able to
continue to provide resources for your
application when and where you need them
despite the same things will surge in
fact you should consider as well how
easily your architects and developers
can design build and deploy on the
infrastructure that your cloud provider
offers right how easy is it to build a
system that's bans multiple zones in
multiple regions and how much work do
they have to do to maintain or roll
their own systems for places where the
infrastructure provider does not offer
the system that you need
and then finally definitely if you have
an application that for regulatory
reasons or other reasons for requires
physical separation you should look at
the physical location of both datacenter
zones and datacenter regions in order to
pick a solution that appropriately
balances the latency of zone or region
separation with the physical and logical
protection that you get from that
separation and you can do all of this
with an eye back to those SL O's that we
talked about earlier how do I achieve my
solos but the minimum overhead and
therefore a maximum of development of
feature velocity so let's now move on to
part three which is how you can
implement and operate a reliable
application right this section is
specifically about what you can do in
your own stack to take advantage of
cloud and also to reduce the risk of the
outages in your own code base and these
techniques build on the steps that we've
talked about so far using service level
indicators using service level
objectives and measuring them and
selecting a cloud provider that gives
you the performance and flexibility that
we want for your own application so
within Google in addition to thinking
about reliability is how do we minimize
failures we also think about how do we
make our service resilient do the sorts
of failures that we're likely to see
when they do happen and we spend as much
time on systems here at Google which
respond to failures and mask them from
our users as we do in preventing those
failures in the first place in this
principle that failures are normal but
we want a good user experience despite a
small but continuous level of failures
and systems pretty much affects all the
phases of system design development and
deployment so I'll talk about two the
most important areas there architecture
and design and then deployment and
operation so for architecture and design
we recommend taking a sceptical position
right and choosing a architecture which
breaks your stack into components those
components can be decoupled from each
other they can be moved around
they can be scaled up and down and this
is something that cloud makes it very
easy to do my cloud already offers
scalable and flexible capacity it offers
multiple independent zones and regions
if you have a modern application design
using micro services right we have
products like those that make it easy to
make components mobile to scale them and
also makes it easy to detect problems
with individual components and onion on
them if you have a more traditional
application that ones and virtual
machines Google compute engine has
managed instance groups which gives you
a similar level of flexibility and
finally the idea of getting resilience
through failure detection and daily
minimization is a key concept right if
you have load balancing that can shift
traffic between different pools of
instances then you can send small
amounts of user traffic for example to a
new version of the application and
verify that those users are getting the
result you expect before you increase
the fraction of your application that
uses that new version and that way you
can seamlessly roll users over to a new
version of the application without ever
to do too many of them at the risk of a
new release at once and if it isn't
working the way you expect you can just
send over your traffic back to the
existing instances that you've got the
version of your application that no
works and then you can debug what went
wrong at your leisure without time
pressure during development cloud also
offers a number of powerful tools to
support best practices like continuous
build and testing for example it's very
easy to spin up a whole new test
instance of your production application
that's decoupled from your actual
production environment and there you can
test new versions of components make
sure everything works together doing
integration tests and spinning back down
and that way by the time you actually
deploy to production you have a great
deal of confidence that the application
is going to work the way you want and
you've taken advantage of the same
concepts of
component groups and scaling that you'll
use in your production environment so
when we talk about deployment and
operation I think of the different areas
of reliability this one often gets less
attention than it ought and I'm not just
saying that because I've spent the last
two decades of my life working on
deployment problems but for two reasons
really primarily that the impact of a
change on an application is somewhat
underappreciated most failures that we
see occurred during attempts to change
in application it's a single largest
positive outage and yet it's not the
place sometimes where we spend the most
time making sure that our practices are
safe and appropriate to the reliability
Karadzic's that we've got and secondly
because change management is actually
hard and historically it's been
difficult to be sophisticated about
change management it can be treated as
sort of a monolithic we have the old
version we have the new version you have
a failover period and that approach is
very very high-stakes you have to get
everything right with the new version
where you have a catastrophe and so
really when we think about deployment
and operation it is a place to take
advantage of a lot of the capabilities
that cloud gives you to drastically
reduce the risk of deployment and the
risk of new versions and then in turn
means that you can deploy much more
frequently and have higher development
velocity and eventually have any more
features for your users which is
obviously a highly desirable trait so a
few tips and this is a deep area so I'm
just going to scratch the surface but
shameless plug for the SRA book if you
want to read a lot more about this in
general the best way to manage a change
and thus minimize the risk of a change
was edit outage is first of all to
practice progressive little loud right
and progressive rollout means that you
apply updates to instances of your
application either in different zones
and regions independently or to small
fractions of your instances first and
then greater
actions as you gain confidence that
everything is working the way you expect
and cloud infrastructure supports you
here both with automated development
tools but also with automated deployment
tools supervision of rollouts is very
very important and supervision in
particular means knowing what you expect
to see and only continuing a little
rollout if the results are exactly what
you expect right no more nor less and
they're different a lot of times what we
see with rollouts that have gone bad is
they weren't overtly failing but they
weren't behaving the way that we
expected and the criteria for continuing
had de facto then well unless it's
breaking keep rolling out right and and
that masks things like oops
you know we're consuming six percent
more memory than we had expected which
is fine at the time you're doing the
rollout during a local trough of traffic
but the next morning in peak traffic
rolls around it turns out that's a
problem right and so this idea of
knowing what to expect and only
proceeding with a rollout when it's
working the way to expect gives you a
great deal of safety for really
extremely low cost and then in addition
to roll out obviously if things aren't
working well your roll backs need to be
fast safe and easy right some of the
outage post-mortems that we've done one
of the reasons that the object occurred
was that the team that was in the middle
of the rollout was nervous about rolling
back when the system wasn't behaving the
way they expected and that has a
predictable result right if your roll
backs are fast and safe and your
application was working before you
started changing it right then hitting
the big rollback button the first moment
that something isn't doing the way you
expect becomes habit for everyone and
that actually it will save you from a
ton of affordable outages and then
finally designing your applications so
that it fails in a way that gives you a
reasonable result we call it fails
static but things like you know you get
a configuration change and you send that
configuration change to the first
instance of your app and that instance
of the app stops responding we're
for whatever reason maybe it's crashing
loop in the crash loop maybe it's just
not able to parse the configuration you
know whatever the application at that
point can say well I'm not sure what's
going on but I know that was working
fine before this change started so I'm
just gonna stop applying changes to the
app fail static and fire an alarm that
asks the human to come to look for me
and this is this idea of failed static
can save you from a great number of
unexpected behaviors during a rollout or
during a change with essentially no cost
again to your user because the
application just keeping used to work
the way it used to work and cloud can
really help you in a number of these
practices because it offers scalable
infrastructure so that you can spin up
and spin down instances you know during
the rollout you can have extra capacity
to run both new and old side-by-side for
example it allows you to test it allows
you to monitor the behavior of your
application and it gives you insights
into the behavior individual components
so that you can look at you know is it
working the way it used to work not just
at the SLO level and for your user
journeys but actually at the component
level and this gives you a great deal of
safety so in summary that was a
whirlwind tour of reliability in the
cloud it's like I said my my life's work
at this point
and it's a very very big topic but we
have at least covered a number of the
most important and most salient points
for building and running reliable
applications in this lab in the cloud
and my goal today really was to give you
a framework about thinking about these
three major steps in your cloud
reliability journey and then three to
those steps to give you some specific
ideas to get you started down the
process of more detailed planning
developing for reliability in the cloud
can require some new thinking and a
change in perspective but it also gives
you a great deal of flexibility and a
great deal of power and I can assure you
from experience it is a step function
right once you've looked at building
reliable applications this way you won't
look at them in the
way very often anymore and I hope this
has been helpful for you both in
thinking through that process thinking
through assessing your application and
your measurable availability goals
thinking through how to select a public
cloud provider or providers and
leveraging the systems and tools and
structures that they have available to
make your application more reliable and
finally to help you think about
architecture design deployment and
operation of your application to
anticipate and work through of life
reliably challenge squeak including
reliability challenges that are
triggered by your own actions as well as
those that may occur as the result
doggedness events thank you so much and
good luck to everyone
you